des décibels qui ne charment pas
forcément toutes les oreilles
[Musique]
ils ont détenu délirantes futuristes
multicolores et pour eux un seul credo
danser danser et encore danser sur le
rythme binaire des musiques
électroniques
[Musique]
Paris vit aujourd'hui un événement
musical exceptionnel plus de 100000
personnes ont défilé cet après-midi dans
les rues de la capitale pour un concert
géant de techno un rêve éveillé pour
tous les fans de cette musique du
troisième millénaire une libération
après des années de frustration
que ça fait de pouvoir danser de la
techno dans Paris comme ça ben alors
d'abord
je voudrais très protocolairement
remercier Jacques Lang qui va permettre
à tous les jeunes de
Golden dramatiser un peu ce mouvement
techno pour dire que la techno c'est pas
seulement de la drogue c'est des jeunes
qui s'amusent car j'entends chouette on
est carrément heureux
c'est le bonheur
la Techno Parade c'est de la sueur pour
danser des heures et surtout beaucoup de
bruit des décibels qui ne charment pas
forcément toutes les oreilles
[Musique]
je suis contre la techno contre la
musique pourquoi parce que ça fait du
bruit voilà
c'est la musique de la danse primitive
pourquoi pas
s'entraîne hein
en fait si j'étais jeune je serai comme
ça c'est possible on sait jamais
alors la techno serait-elle à l'origine
d'un conflit de génération pas si sûr en
tout cas ils n'ont pas fini de sautiller
ces jeunes primitifs grâce à cette
techno parade les musiques électroniques
sont enfin sorties de l'anonymat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce qui était venu pour voir ce sont mis
à danser en sortant à l'air libre la
grande parade a rempli son objectif
montrer la techno telle qu'elle est le
rythme la couleur le plaisir de faire la
fête bref une claque joyeuse à tous ceux
qui pendant des années l'ont qualifié de
musique barbare et dangereuse
[Musique]
une belle affiche pour découvrir les
plus grands DJ Carl Cox Laurent Garnier
mais ça n'empêche pas de rendre hommage
aux précurseurs des musiques
électroniques
[Musique]
au cœur de la fête beaucoup savourent la
victoire il aura fallu du temps mais la
France a enfin compris la techno comme
le football est un besoin de partage
on sait pas qu'elle existe elle est là
pourtant il y a je sais pas combien de
milliers de personnes sur la place de la
Nation des gens on vient totalement
dépolitiser les gens se reconnaissent
plus dans des clans ou dans les autres
ou dans des figures politiques ou dans
l'idéologie là tout à coup les gens sont
ouverts dans de façon pacifique
sans objectif précis
[Musique]
ce soir je crois que beaucoup de gens
ici 250
000 je crois ressentent un grand bonheur
la culture techno appartient à la
culture d'aujourd'hui longtemps elle
avait été mal compris je rejeté écarté
enfin elle est pleinement reconnue et on
sent ici un sentiment de joie et pas
seulement parmi les les praticiens de la
technologie parmi le grand public
[Musique]